sì è natale
in questo magico magico periodo
natalizio non potevo che farvi un regalo
anticipato
vi ricordate quel bel filmone senza
cervello di pacific rim quel film che
quando è uscito su facebook tutti a dire
io sono sempre stato fan dei monster
movie quando palesemente non è un cazzo
vero della nostra arcinemica ma allo
stesso tempo migliore amica asylum alla
loro versione un film talmente
incredibile che i 400 colpi ha
commentato più potente di un alabarda
spaziale qualsiasi cosa voglia dire
lo so che come spara dalla croce rossa
ma è quello che ho sempre fatto con i
film prendere un palese crescione
commentarlo con voi quindi questa è la
recensione di atlantic rim
il film inizia su una petroliera che in
contatto con un sottomarino guidato da
due molto poco credibili soldati stanno
effettuando un'operazione sottomarina ma
stiamo cercando una frattura nella vena
principale vero veramente queen
non so neanche io cosa stiamo cercando
questo è lo spirito giusto per iniziare
un bel buco di sceneggiatura ma perdono
subito il contatto con la base
rimanendo isolate la strumentazione
rileva una diversa fonte di calorie una
massa gigantesca
e cosa sarà mai questa massa gigantesca
un dinosauro con problemi intestinali
non so fatto sta che tutto esplode con
fiamme bidimensionali viene avvisato il
capitano ho la faccia incazzata perché
le sopracciglia nomi funzionano che
indice una riunione con le uniche tre
persone che lavorano in una base
militare sono troppo giovane per essere
qui sono la sorella del regista e sagat
di street fighter una piattaforma non
può affondare una nave può affondare un
bravo big boss che dice cose ovvie che
prendi uno zuccherino avere te che c'è
una grande differenza tra quello che
succede in una simulazione quello che
accade nella realtà
oddio ecco che fine aveva fatto il meme
di capitan ovvio il marin bendato in un
film della rai lum per recuperare il
relitto della petroliera hanno a
disposizione tre piloti di robot ma uno
di loro è una testa calda perché è stato
il primo ad aver superato tutti i test è
un irresponsabile uno sconsiderato si
virgola ma è il migliore che abbiamo sì
ma è il migliore che abbiamo può
suscitare l'intero film senza neanche
averlo visto talmente banale ed eccoli
due dei nostri piloti
siccome non me ne frega nulla dei loro
nomi li chiamerò power ranger rosso il
blu poi vedrete il perché poco prima di
tornare alla base si imbattono in due
teppistelli per riserverei un
trattamento speciale
ed eccovi la prima scena d'azione del
film signore signori a causa di una
spallata a data proprio dal protagonista
a due che non avevano fatto
assolutamente nulla e io dico che sei tu
visto che li hai provocati to [ __ ]
raggiungono il terzo pilota i power
rangers verde ed insieme arrivano alla
base
sai cosa serve questo film una scena in
slow motion completamente non necessaria
turista scene [ __ ] solo quando un senso
ed ecco lì dentro i robot senza
ovviamente far vedere come ci siano
entrati come potete vedere ognuno di
loro ha una luce diversa ammirazione blu
vengono fatti precipitare sul fondo del
mare per cercare il relitto ora non so
se avete capito bene sono stati
costruiti tre mega robot costati 500
miliardi di dollari l'uno
solo per cercare spazzatura sott'acqua a
quindi noi serviamo solo a questo sì e
no in pratica saremo dei netturbini
subacquei in pratica il sì ma con tutta
sta tecnologia non potremo che messo
salvare il mondo dalle guerre portare il
cibo a chi ha fame conquistare la
galassia che ne so no sono pulizie
marina scusa e quanto saremmo gustati
500 miliardi
l'uno l'uno l'uno dio benedica l'america
è tra l'altro c'è una cosa strana
all'interno dei robot quello che i
piloti vedono dall'abitacolo e questo
due schermi con un radar del 1950 è una
mappa del mondo non è che siccome sono
militari allora tutto quello che hanno e
a forma di radar di verde fosforescente
dategli una finestra sti poveracci
attivazione luci esterne
vedete quello che vedo io no no che non
vedo quello che vieni tu anche se è
acceso le luci non si vede un cazzo
finalmente incontrano la belva che ha
distrutto la petroliera è sparito dal
sonar non c'è più niente 3 ma nonostante
stiano guidando dei robot giganti
l'ordine è quello di non proseguire non
voglio che prosegue in questo è un
ordine e vengono disattivati in fondo al
mare senza preavviso cazzo ottima idea
loro volevano soltanto evitare che il
mostro raggiungesse la costa o guarda il
mostro ha raggiunto la costa
fortunatamente rosso non si è
disattivato e combatte la creatura
fucile era tra magnetico
cazzo ma se gli hanno costruito soltanto
per raccogliere detriti in fondo al mare
a che cazzo mi serve un fucile laser o
per le balene arenate e perché le balene
sono pesanti non riusciamo ad esso e ci
vuole un aiuto da soli pò pesanti e se
avevamo i laser fin dall'inizio perché
non ne avete fatti usare anche a quegli
altri due invece di bloccarli in fondo
al mare
ops dopo aver disintegrato mezza città
ed aver sbattuto la testa contro un
palazzo mentre rosso lo tiene fermo un
jet spara un missile e lo uccide il
dinosauro
per festeggiare la vittoria rosso
raggiunge gli altri due in città e gli
racconta tutto contento cos'ha fatto
in mezzo alla gente che lui stesso ha
ucciso ma si piscia gli pure in bocca
già che ci sei tanto ma nonostante abbia
comunque salvato l'umanità viene
arrestato per aver disobbedito agli
ordini
vuoi un autografo scommetto perché ho
appena fatto fuori il lucertolone nola
devo restare per aver disobbedito agli
ordini di un ufficiale superiore
il capitano sopracciglia lo va a trovare
giusto per dirgli che dovrà partecipare
ad una cerimonia di vittoria dovrai
partecipare ad una noiosa esibizione
celebrazione di vittoria politica
eccellente sei stato bravissimo a parte
le 4.000 vittime che hai caldato con il
tuo naso ma bravissimo complimenti sono
un eroe adesso sono confuso prima gli
dicono di non salvare il mondo poi
quando lo fa lo arrestano perché non
doveva farlo poi gli danno una medaglia
al valore film concentrati su che cazzo
gli devi far fare sto poveraccio e
durante la festa o mio dio arriva una
scena così bella registicamente che mi
ha ricordato il fellini d'altri tempi
mentre ballano vengono fatte vedere
completamente a caso immagini di
distruzione e sofferenza
maestro abbiamo trovato il suo
successore
jared con sé il nuovo messia della regia
d'avanguardia con capolavori del calibro
di atlantic rim 12 12 12 e underground
lizard people
wow
mentre il capitano parla con il pirata
popò veniamo a sapere che ci sono altre
uova di dinosauro abbiamo scoperto che
queste bestie sono vecchie di 100
milioni di anni ma ormai è troppo tardi
che ha magari dal telefono dirgli che
troppo tardi si è già schiusa durante
l'attacco del web è ancora capito che
cazzo sia quella creatura blu e verde
decidono di liberare rosso per andare a
salvare il mondo dalla base decidono
anche di bombardarlo
figlio di [ __ ] questo è pane per i
denti
e via ce l'hanno fatta questa è la
storia del signor pier aldo comparsa
numero 47 di questo film stanno tutti
esultando e il signor pier aldo decide
di prendere la palla al balzo andando a
dare un 5 al capitano ma la giornata
prende una piega inaspettata ce l'hanno
fatta scusate è una stronzata mamma ha
fatto morire dalle risate povero
pieralba il problema è che il mostro è
solo ferito ed è tornato in acqua
quindi dopo essersi presi il merito di
qualcosa che non hanno fatto loro grazie
per quello che avete fatto
grazie tornano all'attacco questa volta
con un nuovo sistema di comandi neurali
vogliamo provare che domande
l'unico punto negativo è che se il robot
prova dolore anche il pilota soffre
intanto il piano b sarebbe quello di
lanciare un attacco nucleare su
manhattan per disintegrare il mostro per
il generale banning quasi pronto
all'attacco nucleare parlerò con
ingenerare non potete sferrare un
attacco nucleare sopra manhattan come se
niente fosse ma è troppo tardi
e approdato adesso ce lo vedo come come
fai a vederlo lì come e non dove lo hai
visto non c'è nessuna telecamera non c'è
niente dio
e mentre i militari tentano per
l'ennesima volta di sparargli addosso
nonostante tutte le altre volte prima
non ha funzionato
arrivano i nostri eroi volando enorme
posso volare se e perché cazzo non me
l'hai detto prima che magari mi evitavo
di distruggere mezza città non pensavo
non servisse bravissimo cazzo sei un
genio a suo punto di bianchi che abbiamo
delle armi nascoste siamo un cartello da
combattimento sarà pronta adesso vengo
lì visto senza neanche chiedere lo
scontrino ma nonostante i tre mega zorz
tiago per vincere pirati dei caraibi
riesce comunque a far lanciare l'attacco
nucleare in questo modo posso salvare 10
milioni di persone contro milioni
fortunatamente il rosso riesce ad
intercettare il missile e da un'idea
geniale
madonna santissima bravissimo e bello
sapere che un robot usato solo per
pulire il fondo del mare possa sparare
usare armi e volare nello spazio è che
nonostante in precedenza il pilota
sentisse dolore per una botta al braccio
riesca comunque a sopravvivere ad
un'esplosione nucleare
quindi questo era atlantic rim è mio dio
se è stato divertente
questo è uno di quei film che sai già
dalla prima inquadratura che sarà una
merda ma se sei come me non te ne frega
niente anzi è un incentivo per riuscire
a guardarlo tutto è di questo che era lo
spirito del canale all'inizio fare
quello che la maggior parte delle
persone non riuscirebbe a fare guardare
questo tipo di fin dall'inizio alla fine
io spero che questo speciale per il
milione vi sia piaciuto altri video
arriveranno ovviamente sempre addobbati
a tema natalizio ai vorrei dire una cosa
al canale cielo dove cazzo è la mia
parte di soldi perché ormai ci sono solo
quei fili su cielo e io voglio la mia
parte di soldi scalcia il grano cielo
almeno una cartolina di natale con
scritto grazie
non so qualcosa buon inizio di festività
natalizie